les socialistes se sont installés je
parle pas du président la met du global
dans un confort d'ailleurs ce confort a
conduit nombre d'entre eux à suivre
emmanuel macron pour pouvoir être à
nouveau dans le confort dans un confort
qui fait que hier dans le bipartisme
vous pouviez vous pouvez un moment donné
perdre mais vous étiez sur le coup
d'après de l'emporter aujourd'hui c'est
le multipartisme et vous n'êtes plus
dans leur vie partis ce confort parce
que certains pendant cinq ans sont
passés d'un ministère à l'autre
tranquillement confort parce que bien je
pense à personne je donne du monsieur
donne les indications jordana c'est dans
le livre pour moi y'a vraiment devenir
ministre non plus donc j'ai eu beaucoup
à bourillot peau blanche dit pas ça mais
bon confort parce que certains sont
passés de l'assemblée nationale au sénat
de l'ue sénat l'assemblée nationale
bref voilà et et chacun avait son rond
de serviette dans les médias c'était
tellement simple tellement facile il y
avait ceux qui défendent et le
gouvernement et ceux qui le critiquaient
ça faisait le bonheur de vos chroniques
drame effet les amis frondeur il
suffisait de venir sur un plateau et
dire une bonne méchanceté bien vacharde
on était sûr d'être repris c'était
rigolo
bon ben voilà les socialistes ont vécu
dans ce moment là et à partir de là et
ils n'ont pas pensé aux français